it's a modern Twist on an old joke you
know what I mean it was it was a real
circumstance that happened an
exaggerated instance that really
happened and I went you know this is
this is a classic joke why not give my
own personal modern Twist on it and move
on the joke's like a minute and 30
seconds of people were like all he did
was bash women and I purposely did it
first in the show to go hey just so you
know this is this is the kind of humor I
like to tell and if it's not for you you
are so more than welcome to turn off the
TV right now
[Music]
hello everyone I had the opportunity
today to welcome and speak with one of
the world's most outstanding current
comedians young guy 28 years old Matt re
who's exploded onto the comedy scene in
the last few years
after having put his time in the
trenches he's been working as a comedian
in small clubs and so forth he started
when he was 15 so he put in his 10 years
before really becoming popular he's been
the subject of a relatively dedicated
ccil campaign in recent weeks and so we
had a chance to discuss that to discuss
his witty fast Brave and uh appropriate
response to that cancellation to talk
about that sort of thing in more detail
and also to detail out uh his the the
structure of his new tour and his plans
for the future and and why he's doing
what he's doing and what the role of
Comedy is in the broader world so
welcome to the
conversation all right so I've been I've
been planning this opening which I don't
usually do because I like to do things
spontaneously but but I H I have to get
this one right okay so you got to help
me get this straight okay okay so now
you're a comedian and you got canell for
a domestic
assault joke and then in response to
that instead of apologizing like a good
boy you put up a joke ad site about
special needs helmets to protect the
people who are offended by you and
now to get yourself out of trouble
you're going to come on my podcast I
never plan I was hoping it would make
things way worse I'm hoping we can drive
sales to that very real website about
the helmets yes anyways congratulations
on that I thought I thought the joke was
funny risky and funny and I thought your
response was dead on like one of the
things I've noticed is that people who
are harassed by sensorial minded null
wits almost always back down and
apologize and then my my sense of that
is that a mob comes after them first for
whatever hypothetical sin they've
committed and then they apologize and a
second mob comes after them for that
exactly and then they lessen their own
character by the false apology and they
embolden these idiot accusers and so why
did you decide when when this blew up
around you and I mean in some ways it's
a tempest in a teapot but when this blew
up around you why did you decide to take
the strategy that you took why weren't
you like racked with guilt and
apologetic and because it's just comedy
I'm just doing what's funny to me it's
never any deeper than that nor should it
be for anybody I'm things that my
imagination drums up that makes me happy
reliefs endorsements in my head that
makes my life happier and all I do is
share those thoughts with other people
in hopes that it makes their life easier
well i' I've been watching what you do
on your specials and you you're
continually interacting with the
audience which and correct me if I've
got this wrong I mean a lot of the
comedians that I've spoken to they spend
a lot of time preparing their sets and
practicing but you're doing it's it it
seems to be something something that's
much more akin to spontaneous wit and
that's a dangerous thing to do because
you could easily be not funny oh high
risk High reward yeah yeah well and it's
also that because you're doing that you
don't have a lot of time to exactly
think through what you're going to say
right I mean if something strikes you as
amusing you pretty much have to go for
it and if your if your head's full of
sensorship related thoughts you're going
to be not funny in about 15 seconds so
you have to let the intrusive thought wi
and comedy you have to what what comes
if you're a naturally funny person the
first thing that comes to your mind
should be the funniest thing to you most
the time it Comm it has to be the first
thing yeah you know if you're if you're
writing a multiple choice test by the
way you if you second guess your your
what your intuition about the right
answer you're more likely to be wrong
with the second guess yeah yeah that
immediate response yeah that immediate
response tends to be better yeah well
and it's it's a weird thing because that
thing that's comical inside you that's
providing you with the intuition for the
jokes it has to be in quick rep timings
everything absolutely it has to be in
quick relationship with the audience
yeah timing is absolutely everything you
want to say the the most pointed thing
at exactly the right time and so what do
you think or maybe I don't know if You'
thought about it what do you think is oh
first of all how broadscale do you think
this Rebellion against what you said
actually is how many people do you think
are behind it and why do you think it's
become such a big deal it's probably a
few dozen thousand which sounds like a
lot until you remember there's 8 billion
people in the world yeah and I would say
90% of the small majority that is upset
with me doesn't go to comedy shows
anyway or wouldn't Vibe with me as a
person anyways which is fine they're
probably not that funny I watched a
couple of them today on YouTube I can
imagine oh my God yeah I mean they're
the sort of people that you just want to
what do you want for them you want for
them you want them to spend spend
eternity in a Hell composed of nothing
but people like them talking to them so
Twitter yeah yeah exactly that right but
that's the thing is it's like whether
whether you enjoy what I do or not you
don't even have to know it exists if I'm
your problem if you and I are face to
face and you have a problem with my
comedy that I tell that I admit to the
world right if you just remove yourself
from me if you do something as simple as
just turn around there is an entire
planet behind you for you to go explore
and live the rest of your life you don't
ever have to think about me you don't
have to talk about me I don't like scre
heavy metal music guess how often I
think about it or talk about it 0% of
the time you just remove yourself from
the situation I don't I see no harm in
trying to make people laugh as a general
um intention yeah well I also don't want
don't understand exactly from from a
purely logical perspective what the
people who are complaining exactly
expect from you because as and maybe it
is that they a have no sense of humor or
and and that's highly likely or that
they're doing something we can talk
about which is gaining some kind of
benefit from their from their from their
complaints some virtue signaling I
really see that with the men in
particular well I know I really care a
lot
wom yeah I saw one Tik Tok video who was
like I I have a wife and I found this
severely disrespectful I was like okay
you cuck whatever dude yeah foreplay
yeah what do you want to get more [__]
outside of your wife like chill out
you're already married she already
respects you what what do you yeah well
I used to see when when I had
demonstrations around me which used to
be more common than they are now which
is just as well the worst people I ever
saw at those demonstrations weren't the
herodin women who were screeching like
fish wives but the men that were
hypothetically there to support them man
I tell you I couldn't even look at some
of those guys without having a shutter
run up my spine there's almost nothing
worse than a man who tries to to worm
himself in with a group of women by
pretending to be more on their side than
the women actually are when their actual
motivation is to use that what was that
Gad sad The evolutionary psychologist
who works at Concordia he called that
the sneaky fire uh routine yeah yeah
exactly well and that's actually a
phrase from evolutionary biology I'll
tell you a funny story that goes along
with that this is hilarious and and so
telling so primatologists who studied
orangutans figured out a long time ago
that there are two variant male types of
orangutan okay so there's like
orangutans tend to hang around in trees
they're arboreal but the men the males
who become dominant in the given
territory get so large sort of like a
linebacker football and they have these
big fat pads around their face that are
circular they get so large they can't
really go in trees anymore and the
females come to them but then there are
other males in the vicinity for who the
primatologists thought were adolescents
for a very long time because they look
like adolescent males and they hang
around in the trees but they turn out to
be many of them fully mature males whose
development into the linebacker is
forestalled by the fact that they're not
at the top of the pecking order right
and so their strategy is sneaky rape
Jesus right so it doesn't take much of
an imagination to map that on to the you
know the feminist male who's so on the
side of women that you know he getss to
be the friend who can entice some poor
girl into bed when she's at her lowest
point so it's almost like their own
insecurity and lack of manhood manhood
probably isn't the best word to use but
it it stunts their own Evolution well
it's it it it it it Ena it it requires
that they take a different Pathway to
mating success they can't use Domin yeah
yeah right right right so pathetic yeah
yeah yeah so why did you decide to come
on my podcast I'm a huge fan man I find
you listen you and I have never met I
have I've I I'll be truthfully honest
I've never I haven't done extensive
research into everything you've done but
I find you to be a very kind man and
very well spoken and someone who stands
on their morals and the the realism of
society today and I think that is
incredibly rare and I just highly
appreciate you oh well thank you I
wasn't fishing for compliments but I do
appreciate the fact that they emerged
well I'm curious partly too because you
I think it's fair to say that your
primary fan base is women that I mean
I'm not certain of that but it is the
case okay and and is it almost always
women that you interact with in the
crowd no not at all it's totally total
luck of the draw whatever happens I mean
women yell out the most for sure like
they'll Heckle the most so that will
draw more uh adamants crowd work like
that I didn't necessarily intend on
doing but overall no it's just is that
something that's particular
characteristic of your shows because I
would think yeah right because yeah okay
well I've kind of I've kind of created
my own crowd work monster in a way a
friend of mine put this in perspective
for me if I if I got popular from doing
crowd work which which was a very
specific strategy a lot of it I only
post my Crow because I don't feel like
burning through material Comics build
for minimum a year two three years an
hourong show right I would feel like a
total piece of [__] if I if I let you
pay money to come see the exact same
material you just SOL for free online so
crowd workor being a very unique
circumstance that really isn't to be
duplicated at any other show that you do
because you're not going to meet the
same person who's been through the same
circumstance has the same story to tell
right so this is a very unique thing
that you can share and it doesn't burn
through any of your material at all so
that's why you've been making the
specials on YouTube out of crowdwork
yeah exactly right right cuz you can you
can make them permanent and you said it
doesn't interfere with the novelty of a
prepared show and so you do prepared
material as well yeah I have two full
specials on YouTube that are fully I've
only seen the crowd work okay oh you
watched the red flags one so I
specifically did that special because I
got I was getting popular for doing Red
Flag crowdwork just on Tik Tok and it
got so bad to the point where I'd be in
the middle of working on material and
people would be yelling out like do red
flags or just yelling out like flipflops
or what Mama's yelling out their own red
flags without any context at all so I
was like fine I'm going to do one
special at the biggest Red Flag City
there is Miami at the Miami Improv and
then that's like the final statement
closing the chapter on my red flag crowd
work now I don't do it anymore now
there's I think the special is like 50
minutes long of me just doing full Crow
work for for 50 minutes with with the
people in Miami and it was a lot of fun
I was happy to close the chapter
though okay why did you close it and why
were you happy to close it because it
does ruin the show when people yell out
I wanted to go okay I know you like this
thing I do so here's that now you have
that final product I did this
specifically for you guys now let me
grow to do the kind of Comedy I I want
to do and I'm still growing and I'm
still learning I'm 28 years old most
Comics that are top of their game today
probably just started at the age I'm at
right now so I mean I have a lot of
learning and growth to do right right
right how how long have you been doing
comedy professionally 12 and a half
years so since you were 16 15 yeah 15 15
were you funny before that yeah yeah I
was always like Class Clown making my
friends of family and laugh I didn't
know comedy was a career or even a job
and until I was about
14 and I kind of discovered who like
Dane Cook and Dave Chappelle were and
those those guys were at the Pinnacle of
of comedy at that time so I just learned
I studied them fell in love with the art
form and I started doing open mics when
I was 15 after school on Tuesdays and
Wednesdays and everything just kind of
snowballed and nobody in my family has
ever been to college so there was no
pressure to do anything after high
school everyone in my hometown kind of
does the exact same thing they just work
at like how big is your home town about
1,200 people oh yeah yeah one stop
flight that could have easily been a
four-way stop never any traffic at all
yeah yeah but that's a mark of of
attainment to have at least one in town
yeah yeah I I came from a little town in
Northern Alberta it had about 25 200
people and it was a big deal when we got
our first stoplight which was like
utterly unnecessary they just got a
Dollar General on the out on the
outskirts of town and everyone's like we
got a new grocery store like they are
loving it very simple Town though yeah
yeah I can remember too that when when
the Kentucky Fried Chicken came to town
that was also a big deal when you got a
KFC that's so funny in hindsight it's
one of those places growing up you go oh
this is so boring can't wait to get out
of here but looking back I had such a
wonderful childhood even going back now
I went back maybe a couple of months ago
cuz I had some show what's the name of
the town it's called North Lewisburg
Ohio it's a very very small town about
Maryville Ohio is the closest city to it
I suppose um and I was doing shows not
far from there and had to drive past it
for tour like two months ago and I
stopped through there nothing had
changed and I thought that was beautiful
like I I I live in LA now and I I tour
cons constantly but people get so
wrapped up into what they think the rest
of the world is actually talking about
or actually cares about when it's not
true at all I I saw kids riding their
bikes and running around playing outside
when I'm driving through town I go I
haven't seen that in years people
weren't on their phones people even
people at the gas station when we
stopped in the workers in there were
talking hanging out nobody was just on
their phone scrolling we become so
detached from the rest of the world when
we live in certain environments it's how
long lived in
La it would be 11 years in January oh
okay yeah after I graduated high school
early at 17 and I moved out and just
couch surfed for the first like year
year and a half okay so what did you do
in LA okay so first of all you said you
started doing open mics when you were
about 15 where the Columbus Funny Bone
in the Columbus Ohio I I went on the
comedy club's website when I kind of
figured out open mics were the thing to
start with I don't remember how I found
that out but I remember going to their
website finding out it's 21 and up as
most comedy clubs are due to Laker
license and the owner's email was on
there and like a naive kid I just
emailed the owner I was like hey this is
my name this is how old I am I know I'm
supposed to be 21 and up but if I have
like a parent Guardian with me could I
come in to try the open mic and any
rational businessman would say no I'm
not going to risk my liquor license for
some kid to come in here tell a jokes
like what could possibly come out of
that but for some reason he said yes and
it allowed me an opportunity to go and
practice and enjoy this new thing that I
was just doing for fun I had no idea
anything like this could ever happen to
me it was just something I was doing for
fun to like make my grandpa
laugh and did you make your grandpa
laugh oh my God he was my number one fan
I I I miss him every single day oh oh
yes so so did you have a good time in
Columbus doing this I did but it's most
like most Midwestern towns there's a
there's a ceiling you know and if you
have bigger dreams yet you have you have
to escape you have to go see what else
is out there so so so how so tell me how
your career progressed from colum from
Columbus how many how many shows did you
do at Club what was the what was the Arc
of your of your career so I started when
I was 15 and then I got a manager at a
comedy club in Atlant um over Twitter
believe it or
not well there Twitter was good for
something I know make or break you like
the one time Twitter has been good for
something exactly well this good for
getting canceled actually if you want to
get canell Twitter is EXC yeah I know
Jesus that is its primary use what else
is he it's just negativity it's the
worst app people who thrive on Twitter
rarely do well in life it's so bad I but
this was when Twitter was kind of brand
new so what would happen was Comics that
I was a fan of would come through the
state of Ohio whether Cleveland Toledo
Dayton Cincinnati or Columbus and this
was a time where Twitter was so new you
could access anybody like this was a
time when like Ashton Kutcher was like
the only person to had like a million
followers on on there like at most
celebrities had maybe 10,000 followers
on there you could tweet to somebody and
they would see it and they would respond
so I would tweet to favorite comics of
mine when they were coming through the
state of Ohio i' be like hey I'm a big
fan I'm a kid can I do a guest spot on
your show and some would say no some
would thankfully say yes so who gave you
an early opportunity DL hugley actually
gave me my first ever guest spot uh
which was so funny cuz when I was 15
years old my extent of my DL hugly
knowledge was just so plain where he
play bathroom attendant his smallest
credit to date has to be I had no
realization that he was one of the Kings
of Comedy like one of the greatest to
ever do it and go one of the most famous
tours of all time but he was so kind to
me he gave me my first guest spot uh my
second guest spot was finesse Mitchell
and then it was uh Ralphie May was a
like like a brother of mine uh he's one
that really helped me out in my younger
years but through Twitter uh there was
this comedy club owner in Atlanta who
knew DL for a very long time and and he
saw DL hugle and I just going back and
forth joking back and forth with each
other on Twitter he reached out my mom
and I drove down from Ohio to Atlanta
it's like a 9h hour drive to come
perform at his club for a weekend went
there we hit it off really well he
explained to me the things he wanted to
do for my career and I didn't know any
better so I was like yeah what however
you want to help and my mom was also
like yeah whatever keeps them off drugs
I guess so did that work did did did it
keep you off drugs uh until like my
early 20s yeah I would say not bad
that's probably that's a better time to
start fantastic job yeah exactly exact
I'm from Ohio I'm lucky I didn't brush
my teeth with fent all growing up it was
bad Hometown was so
trashy diversify your savings with
physical precious metals while
stockpiling silver in your home safe
with Birch gold group's most popular
special of the year now through December
22nd for every $5,000 you spend with
Birch gold they'll send you a 1o silver
eagle coin for free text Jordan to 9 98
9898 to claim your eligibility now you
can purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metal Specialists
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket and once again
they'll send you free silver for every
$5,000 you purchase keep it for yourself
or give something with real value as a
stocking stuffer this year just text the
keyword Jordan to 98 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers now is the time to buy
gold from Birch gold text Jordan to
[Music]
9898917350 my Junior and Senior year of
high school and I go down there and I
live on a Comics couch for three months
my entire summer break I go down there
and I'm doing 9 to 11 shows a week I'm
going to the malls I'm I'm passing out
free tickets I'm hanging posters up to
promote shows I'm going in to the comedy
club at 3 pm. to like practice my set
while he throws tennis balls at me and
hon horns and Jingles anything he can do
to distract me to very that was part of
the treat the training regimen exactly
EX and I think to this day I think it
helps me keep my composure in the pocket
like I'm not thrown for a loop when
somebody y out something that typical
exposure therapy from a psychological
perspective right exactly you're afraid
of yeah oh that's cool so what wa huh so
how did he know to do that do you think
that's
smart I'm not sure he's he's a fantastic
guy his name is Gary ABDO he's he's very
prominent in the in the comedy community
he's he's helped out a lot of people
starting out their career like he he was
very prominent in Chappelle's early
years he was like a late teenager
earthquake so he's probably seen people
thrown by hecklers and so forth and by
trouble get knocked out of your groove
well his Comedy Club down there was
called the Uptown Comedy Corner and it
was notoriously known as like one of the
harshest comedy clubs in the country
it's it was a it was a tough environment
like they either loved you or they would
boo you off stage so for me to go in
there as a kid yes you have the novelty
of like he's a kid give him a chance but
far yeah so you got to get them in the
first couple of minutes otherwise
they're not going to sit there and watch
you do 5 or 10 minutes they just they
don't they don't have that patience in
them so I go down there and I get
trained in like one of the harshest
environments possible and in doing that
I meet more comics who are coming
through the club I would pretty much
open for like anybody that came through
the club down there I met a lot of
comics who lived out of La so then when
I went back to high school for my senior
year I knew I didn't want to go to
college I knew comedy is what I wanted
to do so I flew out to Los Angeles and I
took the the chess be the California
proficiency exam which in certain States
is kind of like college where you have
to have a certain amount of credits to
graduate high school the chesp is
essentially a test you can take at any
time that basically test you out of high
school you've learned everything you
need to learn oh really oh that's a
great that's a great option fantastic so
I flew out there took the
test uh came back I had to wait like two
weeks for my results but I I had a good
feeling about it so I was just I was
just going to school for two weeks and
just like sleeping throughout class I
wouldn't do any of the work I wouldn't
take any of the how old were you at that
point I just turned
late maybe I just turned 17 I was maybe
still and so that's after you came back
from La yes right uh came back from
taking the test waiting for the results
got the results back like the first week
of January moved out to my friend Eric
Griffin's couch two weeks after that so
I was about H like four or five months
early from graduating high school moved
out there lived on his couch for the
first couple of months then uh then my
manager at the time his son graduated
film school he moved out to Los Angeles
I stayed on his couch for the next year
and I was just going to Comedy Club was
every single night I would go and just
hang out some of them wouldn't even let
me hang out inside until finally people
would vouch for me people wouldn't show
up on the line up and where somebody was
like well he's here all right so you're
hanging around enough to get your
opportunity exactly but funny enough
sometimes I would get the opportunity to
go on stage and I literally couldn't
step foot in the comedy club until they
were like announcing and Matt re and
then I would have to run through into
the comedy club Go on stage and leave
immediately after cuz I wasn't 21 so
they still had to abide by like their
own rules in a very loophole way and in
doing that I just kind of stayed
consistent in the scene I was getting
more and more prominent stage time I
started to book smaller and smaller uh
smaller turning into larger um TV
appearances which it was some Disney
stuff that led to a bunch of MTV stuff
and then after I left all my MTV stuff I
just became really dedicated to to stand
up and and transferring over to to
acting and and producing and developing
and all that kind of stuff so what did
you do for MTV uh my first thing I did
on there was wild and out I did four
seasons of that I was like the youngest
cast member it was right after right
after Pete Davidson left there to go to
SNL they they needed a white guy and I
happened to fit like that exact mold
went on there learned so that's a very
strange diversity hire oh of course
we're short of white guys yeah let's
call Matt never anymore no no that's
that's not that's not a likely diversity
H but but this it could not have been a
better learning experience cuz I was a
very insecure shy kid and I was going on
a show with Comics this was this was the
re Vamp of wild out this was after Kevin
Hart D Davis Cory hul all these amazing
Cat Williams all these um fantastic
Comics had left the show and they
rebooted it with a lot of comics I knew
from the Atlanta scene who were monsters
Carlos Miller DC youngfly Chico Bean are
all killers on stage and I had to
compete with that and I knew I couldn't
but I at least had to hold my ground and
in doing that I just went through the
gauntlet over there like everyone at
that show turned me into a man with
confidence on stage and I'll I'm so
grateful for that I I can't imagine I
would have gotten that experience
anywhere else so I did a few seasons on
the show and the show was fun I enjoyed
my experience on there but I had a very
Niche role to play every joke I said had
to be about me being a white guy on the
show if I ever to constrained yes
anytime I try to step out of it people
will be like what are you doing I'm like
Oh I thought I was going to do like a
clever joke and they're like no no no no
no do do the thing to do and although I
enjoyed it and I had built a little bit
of a name for myself I was like this
isn't what that's an interesting set of
constraints right I mean it's very tight
set of constraints and one of the um one
of the facts that emerges from the
literature on creativity is that you
tend to get creative responses when
people are constrained very severely
best example I know of that is so
there's a Japanese poetry form known as
Haiku which has very strict rules well
MIT nerds set up a website decades ago
now that was devoted to ha coup that
could only be about the lunch and meet
spam and there's like 50,000 hi there's
literally 50,000 haikus online in the
online Haiku spam archive and they're
hilarious but partly they're hilarious
because well it's bad enough that you
have to just do haou that's like
pointless and and constraining to begin
with but then to restrict it even
further yeah well it forces a kind of
wit and so I can imagine that having the
constraint of only being able to make
jokes about being the white guy must
have also been one of the things that
sharpened your wit I think so too and I
think unless I'm misconstruing this I I
think that's probably why crowd work
works the best for me because I'm very
constrained like I I have to talk about
I have to answer what they're saying to
me with a funny response in association
with what they're talking about I don't
I don't have vast options it has to be
now and it has to be what they're saying
okay so you said that you were a shy kid
and obviously the last thing in some
ways that you would expect a shy kid to
be doing is to be doing online standup
comedy comedy in front of live audiences
and then Taping that that's specifically
devoted to crowd work because I can't
actually imagine a situation you know
maybe if you threw someone on stage and
said like sing naked that would be about
the equivalent of inducing
self-consciousness so how did you get to
the point where what did you have to do
so that your shyness was no longer
making you self-conscious on stage and
and how is it that you Orient yourself
towards the audience so you don't become
self-conscious when you're now now
you'll be self-conscious CU we're deing
no no not at all not at all so so I'm
curious about how how you keep yourself
not focusing on whether or not you're
being funny for example when you're
interacting with the
audience it's purely confidence whether
it's real or fake confidence I think
when I was
younger I did develop a fake confidence
I uh I I I was bullied a lot in high
school not like getting shoved into
lockers but to the point where I I
wasn't any in anybody's group you know I
was PL clown I was the butt of a lot of
people's Jokes
which didn't hurt at least I I I tell
myself but I think that's where you
learn you learn to to to deflect right
you you have two options in a moment
when somebody makes a joke expense you
can either laugh along and play into it
and go with it or you can be embarrassed
and everybody sees your embarrassed
which is even more embarrassing yeah
right that just invites through your
abuse yeah so I think growing up I
developed this sense of false confidence
where I went hey if I also make fun of
myself and I get in on your guys' joke
it won't hurt or people can't
tell think it doesn't bother me cuz
obviously like so I'm going to challenge
your supposition that that was false
well because the thing about being funny
is that if you're false you're not funny
and if you're not funny and you're being
bullied you're just going to get bullied
worse so you were obviously seems like
you were able to generate responses that
were witty and that were funny but
purely a defense mechanism I think it
wasn't for the point of like oh I hope I
get a good joke off here I think it was
I have to deflect what them saying a
mean thing with me saying a funny thing
right but that is that is so I would say
that is a good that's actually a very
sophisticated defense because I mean one
of the things that people do guys do
this particularly in like relatively
rough working job working class jobs is
they'll throw pointed barbs at each
other to see you know are you the sort
of person who gets irritated and flies
off the handle and can't be trusted in a
crisis or are you the sort of person
that can roll with a joke and maybe even
say something funny and so I wouldn't
say that the ability to do that is false
I would say that's a sophisticated it's
more sophisticated form of Defense Than
Physical aggression I mean physical
aggression can be useful but that's a
that's there isn't a more sophisticated
way of
parrying like a pointed remark than to
turn it into something that that's funny
and to toss it back oh well thank you
yeah I mean it was it was a totally
subconscious skill set I had no idea
until right now apparently what I was
even doing so a thank you and B I think
it starts then and then the longer you
do stand up you realize you're funny
eventually you do realize you're funny
Chris Rock talks about this all the time
when he talks about uh when comedians
can't tell a joke on stage and it
doesn't work after a certain point you
know you're funny you're just not saying
your joke correctly where the audience
perceives it the way you want them to
perceive right so you don't you don't
experience moments of global doubt
exactly it's localized exactly so I
think after a while I mean after doing
comedy for 12 years and having had shows
of uproarious laughter and standing
ovations you know you're capable of
being funny and putting on a good show
right right so I think that
confidence is paired with the control of
an audience when you're on stage with a
microphone people are there to watch and
listen to you right they're also hoping
you'll be funny except for the a troll
so they're on your they could be on your
side yes and then once people see how
you can handle that kind of power that
you can be funny that you can shut
somebody down I think people are more
apt to take the seat and just go okay
let me just see what he does right right
they're going to give you more of the
benefit of the doubt exact yeah well and
It's Tricky too responding to a crowd
like that too because
you have to be funny well and this is I
suppose in some ways why you've gotten
into trouble you have to be in funny you
have to be funny but you can't be too
mean right you can't hit a fly with a
sledgehammer your response has to be
proportionate I mean you up the ante a
little bit that's my my presumption you
up the anti a little bit when someone
says something smart but you don't come
out with like the Long Knives and hack
someone to bits of course right because
that'll turn them again cuz first of all
you can actually hurt someone publicly
by doing that which is not good if it's
it's not necessary and second you could
easily turn the audience against you
well this is also again why I think it's
so unfair that comedians in particular
face this kind of absurd cancellation
pressure because the line that a good
comic is walking on is so damn thin you
you have to be playing with disaster in
order to be funny right the things you
say this is one of the things I used to
really like about Sarah Silverman she
would say you could see it you could see
it she'd be listening to someone and
some absolutely horrible thought would
come into her mind and then she'd have
the guts to to lay it out even though it
was like rude and unacceptable beyond
belief I think comedy is purely down to
intent when people are bullying you like
when high schoolers are are making fun
of something about you that's a totally
different intent even though they are
making a joke their intention is that
you're going to feel a certain kind of
way that is what differ differentiates
it from standup comedy every single
thing I say on stage is is said with
nothing but the intention to make people
laugh and I understand it's not going to
make everybody else laugh some people
heal totally differently when it comes
to certain topics I get that and I
accept that I'm not for you but yeah but
getting touchy about that even if you've
been hurt getting touchy about that
first of all that's a sign that you
still have some real work to do and
second getting touchy about that and
then shielding yourself from any
exposure to that is not the way to being
cured quite the contrary you know like
if it's better if you've had a traumatic
experience in your life not to protect
yourself unduly from from situations
that might bring that back up but to
voluntarily expose yourself to
situations where that's likely to be the
case and so it's it's it might be
understandable in that people have been
hurt but it's counterproductive even
with regard to their own recovery oh
Absol you know partly what comedy does
too it has this psychological function
is that it does provide an sort of like
like it's sort of like a horror movie in
some ways you know it's a weird thing
that people will go voluntarily watch a
horror movie because you might ask like
why would you pay to be scared but
you're not you're paying for the
experience of the Mastery of your fear
right and you have right well and then
in comedy you see the same sort of thing
happening is the comedians are always
toying with the Forbidden and the reason
for that in part the reason the audience
participates is because well we often
have to deal with the Forbidden and
often some of the things we forbid
aren't things that we should be avoiding
or forbidding so um Russell Peters he's
a good example Peter when he does his
huge stadium shows it's so interesting
to watch them because he tells racist
jokes Non-Stop and you can you can feel
that there's a palpable demand in the
audience from the ethnic group that he
hasn't yet skewered to be skewered so
that they can show that they can take a
joke that they're in on the joke right
right and so and so the comedians they
have that function of putting forward
what would you say unpalatable truths
right in a place where everyone's there
to do that voluntarily that's part of
the game how far can we push things and
then to get all [__] about that and to
try to cancel someone in consequence I
saw this one guy on YouTube who's
complaining about you you know he said
first of all oh maybe may maybe you'll
recognize him he said that you know you
built your career um as an ally of women
that was basically his point now that
you've betrayed him you betrayed them
with your jokes about domestic abuse and
so he was playing this you know I'm the
friend of women sort of game but he's
violating that contract too which is
that everybody's there in a comedy club
To Play With Disaster and and you know
you're essentially supposed to go along
with that yeah I just don't understand
how the environment isn't taken into
consideration like that is the
environment is the context think of
Comedy like a store like a restaurant
front right you go in there the food's
not for you you you can leave you didn't
have to stop in here it's such comedy is
such a niche field it's not I wouldn't
consider standup comedy a mainstream art
form I wouldn't it's not film it's not
television it's not music it's not as
globally celebrated in in every
household you know so I think I I it
just blows my mind that people can't
just let it be if it's not for you it's
not for you I see what's happening I
think like even this guy that that that
um that criticized you in the manner
that I just described I found what he
had to say and him for that matter
contempt I thought it was pathetic but
this is something social media does is
that his video Even though I don't think
it redounds to his credit has given him
more exposure likely than anything he
will ever do in his life right and so
one of the problems is this is a huge
problem on the social media side is that
we've put
undo access to status in the hands of
people who will misuse accusations to
Garner attention you know and you might
say well why would people want that kind
of negative attention and the answer to
that is well High School shooters will
shoot up a high school for attention and
they'll shoot themselves afterwards
which seems to be run kind of contrary
to their desire for attention but what
that just shows is how much people want
attention and the problem one of the
massive problems with social media is
that it provides people who are willing
to do something like Savage your
reputation
with way more attention than they could
ever
acrew given their own status and
abilities and so what to do about that I
have no idea although apologizing is a
bad idea yeah absolutely not I I'll
never apologize for a joke ever I I I
just find the prioritization of human
beings to be so [__] you're on this
Earth for 80 years let's call it on
average whatever was that what's the
average 83 something like 80 funny years
80 after that they're not so funny I
disagree I think after 80 you get to be
funnier you get to excuse you can [__]
wherever you want after 90 I think if
you're on this Earth for such a limited
amount of time how insane is it to sit
behind your phone and computer and
complain about something you don't like
when you have a world at your hands of
all the things you do like what an
absolute waste of energy time and
emotion starting a business can be tough
especially knowing how to run your
online storefront thanks to Shopify it's
easier than ever Shopify is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage all the
way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you grow our marketing team uses Shopify
every day to sell our merchandise and we
love how easy it is to add more items
ship products and track conversions shop
helps you turn browsers into buyers with
the internet's best converting checkout
up to 36% better compared to other
leading Commerce platforms no matter how
big you want to grow Shopify gives you
everything you need to take control and
take your business to the next level
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're at that's shopify.com
jvp
so what why do you think why do you
think you were
inclined when you when this Tempest in a
teapot emerged to make arguably even a
worse joke because I think I which I'm
very I'm very pleased about by the way I
thought that was actually a master
stroke because you topped what you were
being accused of by picking on an even
lower status Group which I thought was I
disagree okay go ahead I disagree when
people think that joke was intended to
make fun of special needs people that is
that's no no I'm not I'm I'm definitely
not making that assumption but that was
the risk of the misinterpretation of
course inevitably what happened I go but
it was a risk it was a daring and risky
move and I also thought it was hilarious
but now but the thing is that was often
not what happens I mean I've seen
celebrity after
celebrity who are cornered by a small
minority of Their audience right
abjectly apologize and so did you first
of all did you have any guilt about the
domestic violence joke which by the way
I also thought was very funny cuz it's a
completely madeup story like it's it's
it's I went to one Diner and a girl had
like a little bruise under her eye and
it was like a conversational joke that
happened at our table and I went this
this is crazy how do you describe this
hum is is there a definition or a label
for the kind of humor that you just say
the worst possible scenario it's funny
because it's ridiculous because you know
it's not true because you know it's not
what you mean you know it's not the
right thing that is what makes it funny
what it how how is that how what is that
level what is that style of Comedy kind
of irony it's a kind of iron irony it's
not fully sarcasm it's not totally
satire no no but it's a wildly common
sense of humor like a lot of people
share that together and that is who I
want yeah well that's part of that's
part of ridicule I would say like you
know the the exaggeration of something
it's also you know if you take okay so
you took this scenario that you saw at a
restaurant blew it up into something
beyond what it was see it's another form
of exposure there too because obviously
domestic violence is a terrible thing
and there's nothing funny about someone
with a black eye except under very
restricted circumstances but being able
to see one of the things that you do
when you set up a terrible scenario and
then you make a joke about it is first
of all you signal to the audience that
you understand that this was a terrible
scenario and then you signal that even
though you know it was a terrible
scenario there's part of you that can
rise above it and transcend it right and
to make light of it and I don't think
there is anything really more admirable
in human beings than their ability to
make light of a tragedy and and light
doesn't mean to minimize its importance
it means to transform something that's
truly negative into something that's
manageable and IAL one of the things
I've seen with people who've undergone
very deeply traumatic experiences is
that you know that they've recovered
from their absolute catastrophe when
they can start making a joke about it
and my daughter for example had a very
rough childhood in adolescent she was
very very ill and she can tell the worst
parts of her experiences in a manner
that's like it'll bring tears of
laughter to your eyes it's screamingly
funny partly because it's so partly CU
it's so so awful you just can't believe
it right but partly because in
recounting it and sharing it you also
signal that it can be talked about it
can be faced and it can be Transcendent
and got by and that's what you're doing
in real time on a comedy stage it's like
yeah we share this snake pit of Hell
that we all live in from time to time
but that doesn't mean that we have to
dive in and wallow in it we can make
light of it and that's what great
comedians do continually and so I
thought that's what you did with the
domestic violence joke and you added
some nice kitchen related misogyny to
that very rapidly which was a good it's
a it's a modern Twist on an old joke you
know what I mean it was it was a real
circumstance that happened I'm sorry a a
an exaggerated instance that really
happened and I went you know this is
this is a classic joke why not give my
own personal modern Twist on it and move
on the jok's like a minute and 30
seconds and people were like all he did
was bash women for an hour I go did you
did you get to the come there's so much
come in the middle of the show then we
talk about airplanes and ghosts and
monsters it's like it was such a minute
thing that I go hey just and I purposely
did it first in the show to go hey just
so you know this is this is the kind of
humor I like to tell and if it's not for
you you are so more than welcome to turn
off the TV right now I don't want you to
fall in love with me and then get and
then paint a a a wrong perspective of
who you think I am and then halfway
through the show he goes oh he ruined it
I'd rather tell you up front like Hey
we're going to do some dark humor
because this is how I personally Jimmy
Carr does that too he of starts out with
like the worst thing he can possibly say
just establish the boundaries why not
yeah I I I I find I find it wildly
important to make light of of dark
situations I feel like you have two
options to deal with the situation you
can either when it comes to a certain
topic you can either let it take up a
negative space in your mind and energy
to where if the word or topic even gets
said around you you get so triggered and
uncomfortable it ruins your day and the
day of everyone around you yes or you
can find a way to laugh about it find a
way to heal that way next time somebody
brings it up maybe you have something
positive to say about your experience or
how you've or how you've come to deal
with it that can then lead to other
people healing through the same way when
my grandpa passed away my friends knew
my friends bombarded me with dead
grandfather jokes they knew that was
going to help me laugh and get through
that and it was the toughest moment of
my entire life and to this see that's
also a test
in many ways to your character because
your friends knew that even under those
dire circumstances that they could still
poke and prod at you and that you might
be able to manage the situation with
something approximating a sense of humor
precisely when when I used I lectured at
Harvard for a long time on owitz and
that's about as dark a topic as you can
possibly manage and I had the a voice in
the back of my mind constantly it was
dead serious lectures right and The
Voice said continually if you were truly
a master of this topic you could deal
with it with a light touch and I thought
oh my god really like really I'm going
to talk about how prison guards took
Delight in torturing people at owitz and
I'm going to do that with a light touch
and I realized after thinking about that
for a very long time like decades really
that you aren't a master of something
until you can deal with it with a light
touch no matter how dark a subject that
it is and like obviously the darker the
subject the more Mastery you have to
have in order to make light of it
clearly right without going sideways but
but I still do think it's a sign of
Mastery and that's why people enjoy the
laughter so much right because it is a
signal of of Mastery often over tragedy
and what's forbidden and what's dark and
to interfere with that that means that
the woke types who are interfering with
that are actually doing a disservice to
the very morality that they claim to
stand for because what you're doing if
you're a comic is actually helping
people not hurting them and you can tell
you're helping them because they laugh
oh of course and it doesn't need to be
for the masses if you reach even just a
few people you're doing the right thing
I like I said at the beginning of the
podcast everything I do is just to make
okay so I'm curious about that because
well obviously the people who apologize
for offending someone with their art or
their comedy must have doubts about
their own intent right so someone comes
along and Jabs them and says maybe
you're just a me son of a [__] and they
go well you know maybe I should be more
careful maybe they're feeling a bit
depressed whatever they do step back and
doubt themselves so you know and you
could say that there are two reasons
that someone called for their
misbehavior might doubt themselves one
would be that they're narcissistic and
the other it be that they're actually
confident in their intent okay now
you've indicated a number of times while
we've talked that you are confident in
your intent yeah okay so so so if I was
uh like a a persistent skeptic I would
say well you clearly offended 12,000
people that was the number you came up
with why are you so confident in your
intent that your belief in the your own
goodness in relationship to Comedy
trumps the fact that like 12,000 people
are telling you that you said something
offensive because if 12,000 people are
sending that I would say a 100,000
people are saying they loved it and
they've been through domestic violence
situations and they found the joke very
funny that they are actually able to
deal with that situation in a comedic
light right and I I commend that bravery
I can only imagine what it takes to get
through something like that but if I can
help in any way even if it was on
accident that's I I feel great about
okay so so part of what you used for
calibration was the fact that as far as
you could tell honestly looking at it
first of all that you were just trying
to be funny and that that joke didn't
differ from a thousand other jokes that
you've told but also that a marked
majority of people agreed with that they
it got laughs in the club where well
that's kind of how you know right people
actually that bit for the past five
months in
probably oh God 200 cities I did that
joking and opened with it and crushed
every time which is why I kept it for
the special like that's that's how you
gauge a reaction look some jokes won't
be funny I've I've I'm currently
building a new show right now I'm
constantly I'm doing so many new jokes
right now some of them will stay some of
them won't stay you have to G
you figure outs and what do youen you
have to listen yeah okay so that's a
good well that's good too because one of
the things so Freud regarded jokes as a
root to the unconscious like a as a as
part of the royal road to the
unconscious well the reason for that is
that you don't you don't get to decide
whether you're going to laugh if it's a
genuine laugh if someone says something
that's funny you'll laugh even if you're
embarrassed about laughing afterwards
right so the funniest jokes are actually
the ones where you laugh despite
yourself yeah of course right right well
but what that shows is that when you
tell a good joke you're striking someone
very rapidly and very hard in a part of
their being that can't be faked so
there's something dreadfully honest
about comedy because you can't no one
laughs at a joke with a real laugh and
you can tell if it's a real laugh unless
the joke is actually funny and so what
that also means is while you're telling
these jokes and collecting the responses
so you had this domestic violence joke
and you might say well that's risky but
that's not the right question the right
question is is it actually funny and
another question is can you rely on the
fact that it's funny as an indicator of
its moral worth and I think you can
right I think that if you tell a joke to
repeated audiences and you get a goodh
humored laugh out of that like a genuine
laugh then that's an indication that
you've actually struck the Target in the
right place and the people who are
complaining about that have more faith
in their ideological judgment than they
do in the spontaneous reaction of a
multitude of people yes right but it's
entirely what I love about comedy is
it's entirely subjective and the point
is that it makes somebody laugh right if
it does make one person laugh it is
definitively funny just not to the
masses which is totally fine obviously
the objective of having a ex up comedy
career is to appeal to as many as you
possibly can but your comedic intentions
is like is if I get a laugh technically
the joke is funny now it's up to me to
listen and gauge the audience where I go
hm do I leave it as is and I appeal to
this one person which is technically
still not wrong the joke is still funny
or do I do more work on this joke to
properly articulate why I think this is
funny and why you should laugh at it to
try to get everybody else on board okay
so when you're when you're screening
jokes for continued inclusion you could
imagine a joke
that imagine it's it's like this with
pieces of music there'll be pieces of
music that are very very popular that
spread very rapidly but that have no
legs right they're the sort of earworm
that you listen to once or twice catchy
yeah yeah when when you're
selecting when you're selecting jokes
I'm wondering what are your criteria
can't just be that it makes the most
people laugh like I could imagine there
are jokes that have a delayed response
and the faster people in the audience
catch it like absolutely okay so can can
you can you
tell how do you determine which jokes
you
keep like what kind of response are you
looking for the most amount of laughter
is the best possible outcome
however and I don't know how I don't
know how to break this down
psychologically but there's something
about comedians that like and oo
response he said the thing suppos to say
and it is funny not laugh out loud funny
but oh my God he he said it
funny well that's yeah that that's
separate from shock value though like
you're pointing out it's like I can't
believe he had the goal to say that
that's like the gesture in the king's
court fundamentally right is that you've
brought to light something that everyone
knows or suspects and pointed to it
right right and that is funny that you
get an an old response like that but
outr would be so personal too because
that that joke about domestic violence
you saw if if you saw the joke for the I
don't know if you saw the whole special
or the clip of it but you saw a laughter
reaction oh yeah nobody thought that was
funny yes nobody in the audience had a
problem whatsoever if you watch later in
the special I do a school shooting joke
that gets a massive who response and you
didn't get canell for that nobody's
talking about that people only care
about the things that offend them
specifically they don't care about me
hurting somebody else's feelings
potentially it's very selfish I find it
entirely selfish you're going to let me
make fun of other things and make jokes
and make light of certain other dark
topics but the thing that affects you
personally is the only thing you're
upset about it's very s yeah yeah you
well you got to ask yourself too if I
the people that I saw complaining about
you I saw absolutely no evidence in the
way they were talking about your joke
that they actually were hurt or offended
whatever they said was and I've seen
this about people complaining on on
Twitter in particular or in public they
almost always claim offense on the
behalf of hypothetical other people yeah
who somehow they're acting as allies for
or spokes people for which is a little
bit on the condescending side to begin
with if you ask me it's like if they're
offended yeah you know if if a group of
women against domestic abuse had
conjured up a petition against you you
know and it was composed of a 100,000
sufferers well that might be more
evidence than some dimwitted tick tocker
who decided that they were going to be
the spokespeople for these hyp
hypothetically offended victims right or
the women who feel chained up in the
kitchen and it's also as simple as just
being an easy target like I'm a lot of
people just want to not like me so you
give them any inkling of that they go
boom here's the thing I can attach
myself well well well yeah well it isn't
only I think that they don't want to
like you it's that you blew up very
relatively quickly like I mean I know my
fault I would have loved a progressive
rise in my career I didn't know Tik Tok
was going to do this right well but you
did put in the work yes you know it it
it didn't happen it didn't happen
exactly overnight you said you can you
know you were you were in the trenches
for what five years before you had
anything approximating real success how
long do you think uh I would real Su
real success I would say in standup real
success probably nine years nine years
okay okay so we can't say that you blew
up like this but it wasn't sudden no it
had a very long developmental curve and
then right but that's typical that's
typic of success right it even if it
doubles say it doubles every 18 months
if it starts at zero takes a long time
for that doubling to start to actually
show okay but what that also meant was
that and this is another problem with
social media is that you had acred a lot
of status Capital right so your status
Capital would be directly associated
with how many people know you
essentially and appreciate what you do
and what that means is that Hangers On
can now leverage that for their own
purposes and the quick and easiest way
to do that is to complain about you
publicly in a way that looks like it's
compassionate right because there's zero
effort on behalf of the person who does
that and what they're doing then is
stealing some of your acrude Social
Capital and and what's really appalling
about that as far as I'm concerned is
that they're doing that for their own
narcissistic ends which is why they make
public statements on Tik Tok let's say
in the hope that they'll go viral and
then they also do that well complaining
claiming that compassion rather than
narcissism is their fundamental
motivation right very ugly it's purely
clout chasing at it at its definition to
attach yourself to what something else
has going on for your own selfish gain
is so pathetic you don't have anything
else to offer Tik Tok is a massive
platform of a lot of artistic creators
you can't it's everything from people
dancing to philosophers like there's so
much you can do on there you can do
anything any without me right right
right right without stealing from you
cuz that's essentially what it is and
completely lying about who who you think
somebody is right you don't know who
somebody is based on a joke they said
yeah sarcasm ex exists for a reason I
didn't mean the thing I said I said it
because it's funny and not what I
actually feel on the inside so who makes
up the bulk of your audience in your
live shows is it men or women uh it is
it is women but I would say it's
massively changed over the past I'd say
five or six months when when my Tik Tok
status really started to rise at the top
of last year it was wildly predominantly
female I would say my shows from October
of last year till about March of this
year were like 90% women any idea
why it's anybody's guess you could say
it's my face you could say it's my humor
it's I I couldn't what do you think what
do you think well you play I I watched
your crowd work I mean you're good at
you're good at playing with the women
who poke at
yes they wanted to be roasted that was a
very that was a very specific Trend a
lot of women a lot of women hopped on to
like a woman would would Heckle would
yell something out and that's obviously
annoying so you rort with a mean
response comedically yeah and this
caught on people were really into that
like people were coming to shows women
were coming to shows requesting to be
roasted now obviously I don't mean
anything I say I mean shut up and stop
yelling out at shows but I'm
articulating it in a way that that you
know I'm just making some jokes at your
expense it's caught on so heavily I
think there might be I don't know if
it's a fetish or of some kind I know
maybe it's because you dared to do it
you know that's possible maybe there's
an appreciation for well that's what
happens with Russell Peters when he's
making ethnic jokes do you know Russell
by the way do I know him yeah yeah I
don't know him well but we spoke he on
my podcast he's a great guy yeah
Russell's great great and he's been
unbelievably successful and he dares to
make jokes every yeah yeah is that right
that doesn't surprise me and that by the
way what you just said is wildly
important if you're going to make jokes
at a group's expense you have to be open
to making jokes about everybody
otherwise it does feel targeted well and
he he makes jokes about his own ethnic
group more than anyone else's and
they're very pointed and targeted just
like I make fun of myself probably more
than anybody else does that's what
baffles me is when people can't laugh at
themselves nothing makes me laugh harder
than when someone's like making
good that's one of the things I really
liked about British
the BR are so good love it it's the best
I went over there I think it was June of
this year May or June I this year feels
three years long sometime early late
spring early summer this year we had a
bunch of shows out there and I fell in
love with it I would love a reason to
move to London for like a year to just
do comedy out there the the audience
they have a comedy Unleashed group there
well because the com the comics in the
UK have really come under assault and a
lot of them have been canceled and so
there's a group in London um who now the
the who's this Andrew Doyle Andrew Doyle
runs comedy Unleashed and he has that
online character Tania McGrath who's a
satire of a woke feminist and he wrote a
book by Titania McGrath and yeah she's
the worst of the woke feminists anyways
he started this group called comedy
Unleashed and I went to one of just one
of their shows so far in London I
actually read a piece that I wrote for
my little 2-year-old grandson who was
trying all sorts of things on his head
pretending they were hats like old
pieces of fish and so forth and yeah but
anyways if if that when you go to the UK
again they're very much worth looking up
comedy unleash I definitely check I
think the funniest UK comedians are now
associated with comedy Unleashed and
they have these fora in London that are
designed to genuinely be open discourse
events is you can make a joke about any
damn thing you want and everyone who
comes there knows that and appreci I
love that well they're very makes the
shows very funny too as you everyone
goes and they're on the same page let's
just let's just have some fun I would
love to do a streaming platform like
that someday where where creators can go
on there and it's just it's whatever
kind of humor you want think same kind
of setup as like a porn website you go
on there you click 18 and you click 18
and up right you know what you're
getting into same with this website you
go on there you realize you're going to
hear some crude [__] well you should
bloody well know that if you go to a
comedy show you would think I mean
listen I've never had a problem at a
live show ever I have never once had
anybody have a stand up and be like that
was not okay to
say almost 13 years of doing comedy not
once you're obviously not pushing the
envelope hard enough Jordan Peterson
said it
first I love my new hour that I'm
working on right now so much Ed year it
it blows my mind people chose this one
thing to attach themselves on to and I
just
I just think it's well it's GNA it's
going to redown to your credit anyways
particularly because you didn't
apologize so all that's going to happen
as far as I can tell is that this will
bring a lot more attention to your work
and people will be thrilled about the
fact that you didn't apologize one of
the things that I've noticed repeatedly
because I've gone through repeated
attempts to cancel me is that it is can
be quite an intense experience when it
in the immediate aftermath of its
occurrence and that's somewhat
off-putting and destabilizing because
you don't exactly know how far out it's
going to spread or what the consequences
would be but if you didn't do anything
wrong and you don't apologize or maybe
you make light of it in some creative
way then the probability that it will
turn around and flip in your direction
if you can tolerate the weight is
extremely high I don't think that part
of the reason I'm bringing this up is
because I don't think that people who
are in the throws of being cancelled
understand this you can imagine
historically if an angry mob of your
neighbors showed up on your doorstep
with pitchforks and flames and there was
like 40 of them it would probably be a
good time to think these people wouldn't
have gone to all that time and effort in
all likelihood had I not done something
wrong right but now you can whip up a
Twitter mob in no time whatsoever at no
with no effort at no cost to yourself
and probably some benefit and so your
instinctual responses to being mobbed
wrong yeah it doesn't it doesn't
translate to the real world I just
walked through two very packed airports
and did nothing but take like 45
pictures nothing but a positive response
you you have you had any negative
responses you said you had no negative
responses to anything you've ever said
so far when you're actually on stage
yeah but what about out in the actual
world not once never once has somebody
come up to me and said hey I didn't like
the thing you said cuz that kind of
social what I don't know if you want to
call it between a mixture of social
awareness and
accountability doesn't translate to the
real world people know takes a lot of
gold to do that a come up to someone and
say you know that thing you said even
though you don't know who they are
imagine you see a street performer right
they're playing violin on a street
corner they've got their case out with
cash right say you [__] hate violin
violin drives you nuts maybe he's not
even good at playing violin what do you
do you keep walking right no sane decent
human being stops and goes you're
[__] awful to kill yourself what are
you doing out here you're making my life
miserable until I just look at different
direction that's an insane thing to do
and most people know not do to do that
but obviously the internet creates this
this this is what I would believe to be
false confidence and and believing that
they're safe behind this imag AR source
of social media that they don't face any
repercussion because their profile
picture is an anime character and
everything's a private profile there's
no consequence for saying what they say
there's no consequence for leveling an
accusation yeah it's really bad yeah
versus the real word if you come up to
me I can have an intellectual
conversation with you as to why I
disagree with you yes or or I could
smack the [__] out right right that is
also a consequence that is is viable and
that doesn't weigh on anybody on the
internet so it's easier for people to
talk [__] on there versus the real world
where people actually aren't even
bothered and also I had I had to figure
most these people who talk [__] on the
internet and actively try to cancel
people and have no life they're not out
in the real world they're in their house
doing absolutely nothing so you don't
have to worry about that yeah and
they've got they definitely have the
mentality of like mean girl High School
bullies yeah right we're going to shame
we're going to reputation Savage we're
going to exclude those are all go ahead
put much energy in your life into
thinking about me and how much you don't
like me what a waste of your life yeah
yeah yeah so now you said too that when
you posted your response to the
criticisms you posted something I think
that's wildly funny by the way and so
maybe you could explain that to the to
the to this particular crowd but you
also told me in the intervening time
between the two podcasts that that
wasn't a calculated response that you
relied on your instinct for what was
funny so explain what you did so so
funny you sound like a principal who my
parents came here tell them what you did
right yeah exactly lay it out but the
principal actually loves it this is
perfect um so now I had to convince my
parents not to whoop my ass basically
this this thing happened there was an
outrage over a joke that was wildly
misperceived and that's fine you're
allowed to like or not like a joke
totally okay and in response to that I
posted every when you get canceled or or
somebody is upset about a joke you tell
you're supposed to apologize people want
you to back down and shame you and and
recognize what you've done wrong and I
don't believe I did anything wrong
whatsoever so it made me really feel
like the people who are offended by this
were for lack of better words and to be
quite Frank weak-minded so I posted a
photo of me on stage thought it was a
good photo with a link at the bottom of
it and the caption was saying if I've
ever offended you with a joke I've told
here's a link to my official apology and
the link description should have been a
dead giveaway it said click to solve
your issue and when you click on the
link it redirected you to a a a store an
online store solve your issue that's
funny very specific because it's a
little ambiguous of course and then you
click on the link and it redirects you
to a an online storefront for special
needs
helmets I thought this was very funny
and again misconstrue people
instinctually again people get triggered
by subject matter than what the joke
actually is everybody took that as I was
making fun of special needs people no I
don't have anything to say about people
making fun of people claiming special
needs for their emotional fragility
inappropriately exactly I'm saying
andely you need this way more than they
do yeah right and the best part is is
that you clicked on it youing idot they
could have special needs earplugs that
they could wear to comedy shows you
actually fil out all the words it AI
generates what they want to hear all
soon enough that's right you'll be able
to get an AI That's Right AI sensor but
that's what your that's technically what
your algorithm is it shows you what you
want to see it it it it tells you what
you want to hear I was the night that uh
I was like the number one trending thing
on Twitter uh like night before last I
think it was I texted my friend and I
was like yesh and he sent me a
screenshot of his I wasn't even top 25
he goes this isn't nobody cares dude
it's in your circle because it's your
profile you're going to hear about it
obviously but it's it's not to the
extent people think so yes I I posted
this misdirect of an apology and it it
couldn't have went better I was
literally just sitting passenger
passenger seat in a car ride with my
friend and I I was I just thought it
would be a funny thing to do it took me
no more than 45 seconds to think of
doing that I I go hey is this funny and
he cracked up laughing I went n [__] it
I also thought that most of the outrage
was happening just on Twitter and Tik
Tok like Instagram is a far more
personal app I think and so the fact
that people even saw that and and took
it to other platforms I thought was
insane but also proved my point even
more that people who don't even like my
comedy or have never even heard of me
saw the outrage and my response to it
and went oh that's actually funny right
it actually gained me a lot of fans
because most of the world I would I
would feel confident in saying the
majority of people are sick of this [__]
well Mo most people are actually hoping
that a comedian will be funny rather
than politically correct right well this
is the problem I think this is the
misapprehension of people who apologize
when they're accused because your case
is well perhaps you irritated some
people by not apologizing but first of
all there are people that you really
don't mind irritating and they weren't
really irritated to begin with so it's
all a lie anyway nor were they fans in
the first place right exactly and so
when you apologize in principle you
signal to those people that you've cow
out and bowed down but you forgo the
opportunity to appeal to a much broader
realm of people which You' think would
be more sensible if you were trying to
protect or develop your career the
people who look at what you've done and
think oh well that's funny enough so
maybe I'll go check out this guy that
I've never heard of I'm sure you
attracted like 10,000 fans for every
person you turned off yeah analytically
I've I have gained more fans than I have
lost across all platforms
the extremities everybody involved in
this outrage has been nothing but
beneficial because even if you didn't
like that the domestic violent joke that
I got in trouble for which is fair even
I think it's not the best joke I've ever
written at all it's not it's it's
probably the worst joke in the special
and that's fine I do other things I have
plenty of other jokes that are for other
people the response being a perfect
example of that even if people go well
that's not funny but that joke of his is
the
extremities are so loud and so against
each other that once
one group of people whatever you want to
call them people love to make it about
the left or the right or whatever I'm a
very unpolitical person I don't really
use those terms so they might not be
correctly used here but say the left is
so outraged about something the right
instinctually goes you're being so
ridiculous about this if you hate this
I'm going to support this because I see
nothing wrong with it so in doing that
they've completely balance each other
out right right well right and you
probably brought your work to the
attention of a whole demographic that
have necessarily known who you were so
many people commenting I didn't know who
this kid was I actually didn't like him
before but I like this joke that he told
or or I or I dislike you so much that
the enemy of my enemy is not my friend
right right
[Music]
right